لا أعتبر نفسي
جمهوريًا أو ديمقراطيًا بشكل قاطع ، فهو سيقاتل من أجل
المساواة في الأجر مقابل العمل المتساوي
وسأقاتل من أجل هذا أيضًا إلى
جانبه إذا أعطينا النساء فرصة متساوية
للمنافسة ، فهذا ليس مفيدًا لهن
ولأسرهن فقط ، إنه جيد لنا  الاقتصاد
هو استراتيجية نمو يتحدث السياسيون
عن المساواة في الأجور ولكن والدي
جعلها ممارسة كما هو الحال في شركته
طوال حياته المهنية إذا كان القتال من
أجل الرعاية الصحية للمرأة وإجازة عائلية مدفوعة
الأجر والأجر المتساوي يلعبان بطاقة المرأة
ثم تعامل
كأم بنفسي  من بين ثلاثة
أطفال صغار ، أعرف مدى صعوبة العمل
أثناء تربية الأسرة إذا كان لديك
أم وزوجة وابنة وأخت
تعمل لا تريد أن تراها
تغش ، فأنت لا تريد أن ترى أنها
غير مواتية لها كرئيسة
سيغير الأب قوانين العمل التي تم
وضعها في وقت لم تكن فيه النساء
جزءًا كبيرًا من القوة العاملة ،
ما يتعين علينا القيام به هو
تحديث القوانين ، وسأفعل كل ما
بوسعي لجعله  يجب ألا يكون دفع ثمن سياسات رعاية الأطفال
التي تسمح للنساء اللواتي لديهن
أطفال بالازدهار أمرًا جديدًا ، بل
يجب أن تكون هي القاعدة